c'était magnifique alors vous savez hier
soir Emmanuel Macron n'était pas sur
Canal plus il était sur TF1 sur France 2
sur les chaînes info on a retenu 5 temps
forts de sa conférence de presse qui
avait comme thème général que la France
reste la France the France to be
the on va recevoir Gautier Lebray mon
ami que j'adore journaliste politique
qui était présent à la conférence de
presse excellent Gautier Lebray avant ça
on regarde l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a été très très commenté il a fait
une belle arrivée Dieu bénisse regardez
Dieu bénisse président de la République
qui fait son entr HM et je pense que Al
l'URE il va donc ah oui
arriver et le président de la République
donc ah les gens se lèvent quand même et
je leur
remercie bien sûr que cette courtoisie
républicaine est plus que cela
d'ailleurs ce respect B du président de
la République et cette bonne éducation
et bien le président de la République je
vais vous laisser qui est en direct sur
C news c'est la première
fois
Gautier le est avec nous on va voir on
va voir les C on va vous dire ce que ça
va changer si ça va se faire ou pas
merci Gautier l'excellent Gautier tu es
je sais que je t'adore avec un teasing
pareil non mais tu sais comme je t'aime
et comme tu es pour moi je vous raconter
aussi les coulisses parce que je vous
entendais des coulisses parou parce tout
ça était quand même hyper cadré faut
savoir par exemple que notre tout le
monde avait pas le droit de poser le
même nombre de questions il y a un autre
groupe de médias qui a eu quatre
questions quand nous nous n'avons eu que
Laurence Ferrari qui a réveillé tout le
monde dans la salle avec une question
Grou de médiia bah une une chaî info
voilà ceux qui sont derrière ces news
ils exactement ils ont eu le droit à
question la deuxième chaîne d'info a eu
le droit à quatre questions et nous nous
n'avons eu qu'une question avec ces news
Europe 1 Paris Match et
cà avec une question en plus très
percutante de Laurence qui a réveillé
tout le monde dans la salle Laurence
elle est incroyable comm à s'endormir un
petit peu laence c'était quoi la
question de Laurence la question c'était
sur l'école ah ouais bien sûr on vaenir
exactement à la
fin c'est très intéressant ce qu'il est
en train de dire c'estàd par groupe il y
avait il avait un nombre de questions
donc groupe très
sympa c'est mes potes en plusfr j'eme
voilà mais voilà donc qu pas de faute
ils ont la ch nous une le service public
ils ont eu plusieurs questions si je dis
pas de bêtises la vraie question c'estce
que Benjamin a posé une question oui
absolument ah ou c'est une question de
merde comme d'habitude voilà merci
je je suis tellement content parce que
je sais qu' à BFM ils sont tellement
angoissés que jeis j'arrive le dimanche
soir mais oui les gars je vous aime bien
quand même ser en frontal ils sont
énervés ouais ils sont énervés ils sont
enfin ils sont ils sont ils sont
inquiets inqu ils sont inquiets parce
que ils savent que bon il y a le gars
qui fait 400000 avec koe en exclusivité
donc il se ditent bon ça va être
compliqué merci tu
voilà dis-moi goti alors est-ce que tu
il y avait qui d'invité alors bah il y
avait la presse les ministres le cabinet
du Président de la République et puis le
toute façon il y avait beaucoup
d'invités enfin il y avait 250
journalistes mais il en avait qu'un qui
parlait C Emmanuel Macron il est ma du
jeu vous posez une question vous pouvez
pas faire trop long alors déjà moi
j'étais dans la salle j'ai pas pu poser
de question puisque je vous disais il y
avait que Laurence qui a pu qui a pu qui
a pu le faire vous aviez Sonia ma qui
était dans la salle la seule
intervieweuse politique du du matin ils
lui ont même pas donné de micro ouis
c'est intéressant ce que dit gtier il
est incroyable gtier non ça t'a énervé
ça j'ai l'impression c'estd que moi ce
qui ce qui m'énerve c'est le traitement
de faveur de certains par rapport à
d'autres ouais ça te fait chier ça et
quand Laurence se pose une question qui
agace le président mais c'est quand même
rôle des journalistes après fermer le
banc il y aura plus de question pour
pour le reste voilà franchement il aa
bien fait c'est cour version macronienne
je m'attendais à plus ah ouais quand
même 2h30 c'est long quelque chose quand
même bon alors toi tu es allé tu as même
pas pu poser une question et la seule
question du groupe donc ça a été
Laurence Ferrari qui l'a posé Laurence
Ferrari elle a elle a pas ménagé le
président elle a fait son elle a fait
son job je veux dire que Laurence
Ferrari a mis le turbo
oh elle a réveillé la salle
elle a réveillé la salle bah regardez ça
fait 4 He que j'en parle donc vous
l'avez calé
j'espère l'éducation nationale la plus
chère au monde au classement PISA vous
le savez nous ne brillons pas notamment
en math vous voulez qu'il chante la
Marseillaise pratiquement un jeune sur
deux ne sait pas situer la Révolution
française 48 % des professeurs disent se
censurer lorsqu'ils enseignent
l'histoire dans leur classe un sur deux
à peur en classe peur de la violence des
élèves des parents et des terroristes la
France doit rester la France bien sûr
comment faire de ces jeunes des citoyens
éclairés donnez-moi CIN mesures
concrètes j'ai le sentiment de donner
une vision et des mesures concrètes je
crois que vous venez vous-même de poser
une question et de donner votre vision
et ceci étant dit ceci étant dit les
mesures concrètes je vous les ai donné
est je ve bien dire un mot là-dessus
parce que il y a deux choses déjà le
président est énervé parce qu'on lui
pose une question un peu plus véhémante
que les précédentes et ensuite vous avez
entendu les rires dans la salle les rir
dans la salle après la l'attaque
d'Emmanuel Macron contre Laurence la
confraternité à ses limites moi je
trouve que Laurence elle est excellente
et je trouve que lui il est excellent
très bon en fait les deux se défendent
avec leur arguments moi je trouve que
Laurence Ferrari comme tous les soirs
sur punchline elle est incroyable et je
trouve que lui dans son exercice bah il
sait y faire quoi à l'oral il est très
très fort on peut être totalement en
désaccord avec lui d'un point de vue
politique et idéologique mais force de
constater que il maîtrise cet exercice
de manire il est très fort mais il
s'écoute quand même énormément parler le
téléspectateurs moi aussi je m'écoute
moi aussi tout le monde s'écoute
d'accord maisré tout d'accord sur ce
le problème c'est toujours le décalage
entre le fond et la forme c'est que
effectivement il est très très bon sur
la forme d'un point de vue de la
communication il est capable de tenir la
salle pendant 2 he et quart après quand
on va regarder sur les actes c'est autre
chose absolument oui mais il dira qu'il
donne le cap et que les les actes c'est
après le gouvernement de le faire il pas
donné il a pas donné de cap il a fait un
truc de Premier ministre il a remplacé à
Cap droite quand vous citez un slogan d'
zour pour que la France reste la France
mais après c'est le même qui vous
expliquer que les émeutes c'est parce
que le le bac c'est à cause de
Jean-Michel Blanquer parce que les
épreuves du bac ont été avancées il a dû
être content d'ailleurs Jean-Michel
Blanquer ah mais après quand tu parles
des éutes en disant que c'est lié à
loisiveté on peut s'interroger quand
même ah oui voilà non c'est parce que le
bac a été avancé voilà alors moi la Seu
le seul truc qui m'a dérangé moi dans
cette extrait c'est de voir la tête de
de Benjamin duel derrière le reste
absolument
pas savez je sais reconnaître les tê
parmi ces annonces il y avait celle
d'une tenue unique synonyme d'uniforme
qui sera testée C dans une centaine
d'établissements regardez tenue unique
ça n'est pas innocent et moi j'aime bien
la méthode que le gouvernement a décidé
d'employer qui est pragmatique on
expérimente on évalue on est transparent
et on regarde pour l'expérimentation on
va même accompagner les famille ce sera
pris en charge par les collectivités
locales et l'État et on va mettre les
meilleurs experts ils vont évaluer
qu'est-ce que ça fait est-ce qu'on
apprend mieux est-ce que ça change rien
est-ce que ça crée des tensions est-ce
que le débat public sera ainsi éclairé
c'est ça une démocratie
adulte et à l'Ô de ce qui aura été
évalué on dira ça marche ça marche pas
ça sert à rien et on décidera de le
généraliser ou pas alors oui c'est des
Magos mais non c'est génial ça tout le
monde le veut l'uniforme tout le monde
le veut l'uniforme et toi tu devrais le
prendre parce que tu t'habit tellement
mal au moins ça t'arranger non mais
reproché justement d'être vague au moins
là il est conr c'est une mesure concrète
ouais non mais là je suis dis là tu mais
on on a pas demandé en fait oui non on
fait pas faire un débat à chaque fois
d'accord non mais je te le dis merci tu
peux dire g qu'est-ce que tu en penses
c'est stupide c'est rétrograde on ait on
a fait un débat ici pendant 2 he bien vu
que les Français sont pour regarde les
sondages tous les Français sont pour il
y a 8% des Français qui sont pour es
toujours dans es toujours ta voix ne
porte pas parce que tu es toujours dans
la voix ce qu'on
écoute ou je te le dis on rappelle que
ça fonctionne dans les
terletre chon pourendre
des en tout cas les Français sont
pouressayons exactement essayons tu vois
bien d'essayer déjà après il a également
mis la Marseillaise au centre de son
projet hein Mar tu sais que ça existe
déjàend déjà la Marseillaise à l'école
donc ça c'est une non annonce voilà donc
il a le secr je sais pas quoi mon fils
il il connait la Marseillaise dans le
pas est dans crois dans les coulisses
faites entrer en plateau
etant il est pas trop sur la Marc il
fait du business en
coulisse